[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRUNO DENUIT: Hi.
I'm Bruno.
I'm the Chief Software
Architect at EnPlug.
We are the first open software
platform for digital signage.
In this video, I
would like to show you
how you can use the EnPlug
platform to develop an app
and deploy your content to any
physical device in the world.
So when we started
EnPlug, we decided
to go with the Android platform,
because it's an open platform.
It's very popular, and it
also let us run our software
on inexpensive hardware.
We decided to make our
software an open platform
so that the people
who want to bring
their content into
the digital world
could focus on their
value add by building
an app on our
platform, and wouldn't
have to worry about
all the details
that we had to worry about.
So how do you start doing that?
How do you start writing an
app for the EnPlug platform?
Go to developers.enplug.com.
Sign up and download our SDK.
Our SDK is made up of two parts.
Obviously, there is the SDK
for actually writing the app
that we run on the devices.
It will run for
Android, but it also
runs in desktop, Mac and
Windows, and now Chrome OS,
like I mentioned.
And the other part is
if you want your app
to be more customized, if
there are certain configuration
settings that you want
the user to select,
then you can use our web
SDK to create a web page,
and have the user save
all these configuration
and things in EnPlug.
We have two examples on
GitHub of sample apps
that you can download
and use out of the box.
The first one is
a very simple app
that allows you to show
any kind of web page.
So you can get going
from the start.
Just download that app,
point it to your websites,
and it will start
showing on the screen.
The second app is
for people who want
to go a little bit further
and create their own app,
customize their own app.
And that contains a
framework for creating an app
on our platform.
So here you have an
example of our web app
where you can configure
your different apps.
You can toggle them on and off.
I selected Waitlist.me app
to show how to configure it.
You can go and configure
your Waitlist app.
It asks you to connect with
an account on Waitlist.me.
So this is an example of the
integration between EnPlug
and a third party.
Type in your credentials
for Waitlist.
You select the location that
you are checked in with.
And type some
text, some tagline.
Minimum number of people.
These are all configuration
settings for Waitlist.me.
You save it, and it
shows up preview of how
your screen will look like.
I hope you check out EnPlug.
Go to developers.enplug.com.
Sign up, download our SDK, try
it out, and you'll see how easy
and how much fun you will have.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]